dormir ça fait du bien de dormir
commence bien cette vidéo on sent qu'on
va apprendre des trucs tout de suite bon
en vrai dormir au-delà du fait que ça
fait du bien parce que c'est agréable ça
fait aussi du bien à notre cerveau à
notre corps donc ça fait du bien à notre
santé donc dormir ça nous fait du bien
mais à l'inverse si on dort pas ou si on
dort pas assez
[Musique]
ah alors qu'est-ce qui se passe si on
dort pas assez d'ailleurs qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire pas dormir assez est-ce que
ça peut vraiment nous rendre malade si
on dort pas suffisamment et même est-ce
que c'est vrai que si on nous empêche de
dormir on meurt carrément avant de
répondre à toutes ces questions un petit
mot sur Emma qui sponsorise cette vidéo
et c'est pas la première fois donc je
les remercie pour deux raisons d'abord
parce que bah ça me permet de vous faire
du contenu et puis ensuite parce que du
coup bah je suis full équipé ma
maintenant le linge de lit les oreillers
à mémoire de forme la couette et cetera
la totale j'avais même le sur matelas à
mémoire de forme mais la dernière fois
si vous vous souvenez bien j'avais testé
leur matelas hybride premium je l'avais
commandé pour quelqu'un qu'on avait
besoin et qui m'invite souvent à dormir
et franchement j'ai kiffé donc cette
fois je m'en suis pris un pour moi aussi
alors je vous explique un peu comment ça
marche vous allez sur le site d'Emma
vous choisissez ce dont vous avez besoin
et ensuite votre commande arrive bien
emballer dans un carton facile à ouvrir
la livraison elle est gratuite et le
retour aussi oui parce que vous pouvez
essayer les produits pendant s Nui et
les renvoyer s'il vous conviennent pas
ah et vous m'aviez posé une question la
dernière fois dans les commentaires donc
je me su renseigné non vous n'avez pas
besoin de remettre le matelas dans le
carton si vous voulez le renvoyer vous
appelez le service client et ils
viennent le chercher chez vous une autre
question qu'on m'a posé aussi les délais
de livraison ces derniers mois j'ai
demandé aussi et voilà ce qu'on m'a dit
après les promos précédentes il y a eu
énormément de commandes donc il y a eu
des ruptures de stock donc des délais de
livraison allongé mais on m'a dit que la
situation est rétablie et que les
produits sont de nouveau disponibles si
vous avez des questions ou des soucis et
n'hésitez pas à contacter Emma les
matelas ils sont garantis 10 ans le
matelas hybride a été primé SEP fois en
Europe et le hybride 2 a été le meilleur
matelas testé en France en 2023 et bien
sûr j'ai un petit cadeau pour vous 10 %
de réduction avec le CODE corp YT c'est
marqué là 10 % de réduction en plus des
promos qu'il y a jusqu'au 6 février qui
peuvent déjà aller jusqu'à - 50 % je
vous ai mis le lien dans la description
vous avez juste à cliquer dessus et à
vous faire plais mais donc la question
du jour enfin une des questions du jour
parce que vous allez voir qu'il y en a
plusieurs c'est ne pas assez dormir
est-ce que c'est
dangereux bon déjà qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire ne pas assez dormir oui ça fait
déjà deux questions je vous avais
prévenu alors combien de temps il faut
dormir pour être bien 8h il faut dormir
8h ah bah ça je le sais alors là tu peux
y aller mon con c'est vrai qu'on entend
souvent dire qu'une bonne nuit c'est 8h
de sommeil c'est pas complètement faux
mais c'est pas complètement vrai ça
dépend de l'âge qu'on a déjà quand on
vient de naître on peut dormir jusqu'à
18h par jour quand on a 8 ans c'est un
peu plus de 10h au moment de
l'adolescence c'est entre 8 et 10h par
nuit et quand on arrive à l'âge adulte
c'est entre 7 et 9h et puis ça diminue
un petit peu après 65 ans oui donc en
gros 8h quoi hein donc j'avais raison
oui tu avais un peu raison c'est vrai
bah ouais voilà mais en même temps ce
chiffre il veut absolument rien dire bah
si 8h ça veut dire 8h en fait allô ça
veut rien dire parce que c'est une
moyenne et que du coup ça peut beaucoup
varier d'un individu à l'autre et oui
parce que en plus de l'âge il y a plein
d'autres facteurs qui font varier le
temps de sommeil dont on a besoin l'état
de santé par exemple si on est malade on
a besoin de dormir plus pour que notre
corps puisse se remettre puis notre
activité physique aussi est-ce qu'elle a
été importante pendant la journée ou pas
trop il y a plein de facteurs qui
entrent en jeu mais le principal truc
qui fait qu'on a pas tout et tous besoin
du même nombre d'heures de sommeil c'est
celui-là le sommeil il a plusieurs phase
endormissement sommeil léger sommeil
profond vous vous souvenez on a déjà
parlé de tout ça ici quand on est passé
par chacune de ces phases on a bouclé ce
qu'on appelle un cycle de sommeil et ça
recommence et c'est là que la différence
se fait non seulement on n pas toutes et
tous des cycle de la même durée mais en
plus on n' a pas le même nombre par nuit
on dit qu'on aurait entre 3 et 6 cycles
par nuit et qui durerait chacun entre
une et 2 he environ vous voyez ça peut
vite faire des groses donc il y en a qui
sont en forme après genre 6h de sommeil
et il y en a d'autres qui ont besoin de
9 10h c'est comme ça par contre ce qu'on
sait c'est que en dessous de 6h de
sommeil les problèmes commencent on est
en dette de sommeil comme on dit on va
parler des conséquences mais avant il y
a un truc qui est au moins aussi
important que la quantité que que le
nombre d'heures dormis c'est la qualité
du sommeil le problème c'est que c'est
pas facile à évaluer he vu que par
définition pendant ce temps-là on dort
quoi on n'est pas forcément objectif et
puis on peut même avoir un ressenti
complètement faussé il y a des gens qui
peuvent avoir l'impression d'avoir passé
une nuit horrible genre de pas avoir
fermé l'œil pratiquement alors qu'en
fait pas du tout ça par exemple ça
s'appelle une insomnie paradoxale
heureusement il y a des moyens de
déterminer objectivement la quantité et
la qualité de notre sommeil comme de
tenir un agenda du sommeil par exemple
si vous connaissez pas je vous mets un
exemple dans la description de la vidéo
mais ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que il y
a vraiment plein de truc qui détériore
la qualité de notre sommeil l'alcool par
exemple ça on dort ok mais on dort mal
et c'est pas un sommeil réparateur comme
on dit le stress aussi hein globalement
l'état psychologique dans lequel on est
ça influence beaucoup la qualité de
notre sommeil il y a la température
aussi on sait qu'on dort moins bien
quand il fait chaud il y a notre état de
santé hein globalement comme la douleur
par exemple qui perturbe le sommeil ou
des conditions particulières comme
l'apnée du sommeil dont on avait déjà
parlé ici avec Ben de notabéné l'état
dans lequel on est quand on va se
coucher l'énervement l'activité physique
qu'on a eu notre exposition aux écrans
et cetera et cetera c'est important de
connaître tout ça pour pouvoir se mettre
dans les meilleures conditions pour
dormir on avait parlé de ça aussi dans
une autre vidéo je vous la remets aussi
donc il y a pas assez dormir mais il y a
mal dormir aussi les deux ont des
conséquences bon ok mais du coup c'est
c'est dangereux ou parce que bon bon bah
déjà si on dort pas assez ou qu'on dort
mal il y a des trucs qui sont assez
évidents qui sautent aux yeux et dont on
se rend compte tout seul assez
facilement on manque d'énergie à la fois
physiquement et psychologiquement au
niveau de l'humeur
c'est pas ouf non plus on est irritable
on a pas trop le moral et cetera on a du
mal à se concentrer et à réfléchir de
façon efficasses nos gestes sont moins
précis moins bien coordonnés que
d'habitude bref il y a tout un tas de
signes physiques et psychologiques qui
montrent que il y a quelque chose qui
manifestement se passe pas aussi bien
que d'habitude et ça dès la première
mauvaise nuit donc ça c'est bien le
signe qui se passe quelque chose de pas
génial mais à long terme est-ce qu'il y
a vraiment des conséquences pour
comprendre ce qui se passe à long terme
si on dort pas assez ou qu'on dort mal
ou les deux il faut déjà comprendre ce
qui se passe dans notre corps pendant
qu'on dort et à quoi ça sert de le faire
et vous allez voir que du coup bah ce
qui se passe dans le cas contraire tout
de suite ça devient beaucoup plus clair
vous avez sans doute déjà entendu votre
tonton ou votre Tati vous dire un truc
du genre ah bah moi c'est pas dur je
suis réglé comme une horloge alors là tu
peux y aller bon alors en général c'est
pour vous parler de son transit
intestinal mais si on regarde les choses
de manière un petit peu plus globale il
faut bien reconnaître que tantine ou
tonton bah ils ont raison on a une
horloge celle qu'on appelle notre
horloge biologique ou notre horloge
interne on en a même plusieurs qui
déterminent ce qu'on appelle le rythme
circadien alors c'est pas un rythme qui
jongle avec des bolass enflammé c'est le
rythme qui gère et qui régule toute
notre petite machinerie interne ce
rythme il dure à peu près 24 he et il
comprend notamment le rythme veille
sommeil et même s'il y a plusieurs
théories là-dessus la plus communément
admise c'est que la veille c'est pour
agir et le sommeil c'est pour récupérer
concrètement quand on dort tout notre
organisme il fonctionne au ralenti nos
muscles se relâchent complètement notre
activité cérébrale ralentit de plus en
plus notre cœur et notre respiration
aussi et même notre température diminue
et tout ça ça va nous permettre un de
faire le ménage et de de réparer ce qui
a été utilisé pendant la journée comme
par exemple éliminer les déchets et les
substances nocives générées par nos Act
ité de la journée l'acide lactique par
exemple on en a besoin pour faire
marcher nos muscles mais si on en a trop
après avoir fait du sport par exemple ça
peut provoquer des douleurs des crampes
voire des trucs un peu plus graves et
puis a notre cerveau aussi qui en
profite pour éliminer ses déchets à lui
et pour faire le ménage dans son réseau
de neuron on sait que le sommeil ça
permet de faire le tri et de renforcer
notre mémoire mais aussi de réorganiser
nos connexions neuronales ça renforce
notre cerveau ça le rend plus efficace
mais pendant qu'on dort notre corps il
se contente pas d'évacuer des trucs
toxiques il profite aussi que il est un
petit peu au calme pour fabriquer des
choses dont on a besoin il sécrète tout
un tas de substance super importante
comme une grande partie de l'hormone de
croissance par exemple et on sait aussi
que le sommeil il est indispensable au
bon fonctionnement de notre système
immunitaire voilà ça c'est juste
quelques exemples pour que vous
compreniez à quoi notre corps s'occupe
pendant qu'on dort quand on a
l'impression qu'il fait rien en gros
pour résumer pendant qu'on dort tout
ralentit et l'énergie qu'on économise
notre organisme il peut s'en servir pour
faire tout un tas de trucs importants et
principalement se réparer et se préparer
pour la suite du coup à l'inverse bah
oui vous êtes malin vous avez compris si
on dort pas assez bah le corps il se
répare mal et il se prépare pas bien
pour la suite du coup on abîme nos
organes plus rapidement le cœur le
cerveau et cetera parce qu'en plus de
pas bien récupérer en plus de pas
éliminer les déchets quand on dort mal
ou qu'on dort pas assez on sécrète aussi
des substances nocives par exemple des
substances qui augmentent le risque de
maladie cardio-vasculaire au niveau du
cœur et des vaisseaux donc et aussi le
risque d'obésité par exemple on sait que
quand on est en dette de sommeil on est
plus facilement attiré par les aliments
gras et les aliments sucrés à plus ou
moins long terme pas assez de sommeil ou
un sommeil de mauvaise qualité ça a des
conséquences négatives sur notre santé
celle dont je viens de parler donc mais
aussi ça augmente le risque de faire un
AVC ça augmente le risque de se blesser
au niveau des muscles et au niveau des
EOS ça nous rend plus vulnérabl aux infs
et même à certains cancers le système
immunitaire vous vous souvenez on a
aussi plus de risque de développer
certaines maladies comme le diabète de
type 2 par exemple ça diminue nos
capacités cognitives c'est-à-dire la
capacité à apprendre des choses à
réfléchir de façon efficace notre
mémoire et cetera ça a un impact fort
sur notre état psychologique ça favorise
les états dépressifs par exemple chez
les enfants ça peut perturber la
croissance et chez les adultes un
déficit en hormone de croissance ça a
des répercussions sur la force
musculaire la solidité des et cetera et
cetera bref vous avez compris ne pas
dormir assez ou pas assez bien ça a
plein de conséquences négatives ah et
donc si on dort pas bah on meurt
carrément c'est ça bah il y a plusieurs
expériences qui ont été menées sur le
sujet oui on a empêché des gens de
dormir pour voir ce que ça faisait pour
voir s'il mourrait par exemple chacun
ses hobby moi je la plus célèbre c'est
celle de Randy Gardner un Californien de
17 ans on en a déjà parler ici mais en
gros il est resté éveillé pendant 11
jours sous surveillance médicale et non
seulement il est pas mort mais en plus
on s'est rendu compte que certains de
ces neurones se mettaient en pause
pendant que les autres continuaient à
fonctionner il faisait des tours de
garde pour que tout le monde puisse se
reposer en fait depuis il y a d'autres
expériences qui ont été menées et qui
ont toutes déduit que ne pas dormir non
ça ne nous tue pas pas tout de suite en
tout cas hein parce qu'on a vu qu'à long
terme ça diminue quand même pas mal
notre espérance de vie mais par contre
il y a un truc qui arrive très très
rapidement avec la privation de sommeil
c'est les effets psychologiques
d'ailleurs c'est utilisé comme torture
confusion délire hallucination paranoïa
et état dépressif et cetera quand on
dort pas direct ça arrive au bout de
quelques jours et vous avez peut-être
entendu parler d'une expérience appelée
le Russian sleep experiment qui a été
mené dans les années 40 on avait enfermé
cinq prisonniers russes dans une pièce
qui était régulièrement remplie d'un gaz
qui les tenait éveillé et on leur avait
fait croire que s'ils arrivaient à ne
pas dormir pendant 30 jours ils seraient
libérés l'expérience elle avait dû être
arrêté parce que les pauvres Bou soit
ils étaient devenus complètement fous
soit ils s'étaient automutilés soit ils
étaient morts
soit les trois et ben le Russian sleep
experiment l'expérience du sommeil russe
c'est une creepy pasta une nouille
flippanteah en fait c'est juste une
légende urbaine qu'on se raconte autour
d'un feu de camp avant de se faire
découper si on vit dans un film
d'horreur c'est une légende urbaine
c'est ça que je veux dire bon mais
qu'est-ce qu'on retient de tout ça que
si on dort pas du tout on meurt pas tout
de suite mais on devient fou et on meurt
plus jeune que si on dort pas assez ça
permet pas à notre corps de se remettre
de la journée précédente et de se
préparer à la journée suivante et que ça
a des conséquences négatives sur notre
santé mais attention et on va se quitter
là-dessus il y a plusieurs études qui
ont montré que trop dormir c'était aussi
mauvais que pas assez dormir donc en
gros moins de 6 he c'est pas assez plus
de 9 10h c'est trop mais évidemment
c'est des moyennes hein il y a toujours
des cas particuliers commenz pas à
gueuler voilà dtess c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là prenez
soin de vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez-vous bien et surtout j'entends
rien portez-vous
[Musique]
bien